[Music]
I have spent the past few years putting
myself into situations that are usually
very difficult and at the same time
somewhat dangerous I went to prison
difficult I worked in a coal mine
dangerous I filmed in war zones
difficult and dangerous and I spent 30
days eating nothing but this fun in the
beginning a little difficult in the
middle very dangerous in the end in fact
most of my career I have been immersing
myself into seemingly horrible
situations for the whole goal of trying
to examine societal issues in a way that
make them engaging that make them
interesting that hopefully break them
down in a way that make them
entertaining and accessible to an
audience so when I knew I was coming
here to do a TED talk that was gonna
look at the world of branding and
sponsorship I knew I would want to do
something a little different so some of
you may or may not have heard a couple
weeks ago I took out an ad on eBay I
sent out some Facebook messages some
Twitter messages and I gave people the
opportunity to buy the naming rights to
my 2011 TED talk that's right some lucky
individual corporation for-profit or
nonprofit was going to get the
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity because
I'm sure Chris Anderson will never let
it happen again
- by the naming rights to the talk
you're watching right now that at the
time didn't have a title didn't really
have a lot of content and didn't really
give much hint as to what the subject
matter would actually be so what you
were getting was this your name here
presents my TED talk did you have no
idea what the subject isn't depending on
the content could ultimately blow up in
your face especially if I make you or
your company look stupid for doing it
but that being said it's a very good
media opportunity you know how many
people watch these TED Talks it's a lot
that's just a working title by the way
so even with that caveat I knew that
someone would buy the naming rights now
if you'd have asked me that a year ago I
wouldn't been able to tell you that with
any certainty but in the new project
that I'm working on my new film we exam
in the world of marketing advertising
and as I said earlier I put myself in
some pretty horrible situations over the
years but nothing could prepare me
nothing could ready me for anything as
difficult or as dangerous as going into
the rooms with these guys
you see I had this idea for a movie what
I want to do is make a film all about
product placement marketing and
advertising where the entire film is
funded by product placement marketing
and advertising so the movie will be
called the greatest movie ever sold so
what happens in the greatest movie ever
sold is that everything from top to
bottom from start to finish is branded
from beginning to end you know from the
above the title sponsor that you'll see
in the movie which is Brand X now this
brand the Qualcomm Stadium the you know
Staples Center these people will be
married to the film in perpetuity
forever and so the film explores this
whole idea
it's what in perpetuity period forever
but not only we're gonna have the Brand
X title sponsor but we're gonna make
sure we sellout every category we can in
the film so maybe we sell a shoe and it
becomes the greatest shoe you ever wore
the greatest car you ever drove from the
greatest movie ever sold you know the
the greatest drink you've ever had Kurt
see the greatest movie ever sold so the
idea is beyond just showing that brands
are part of life but actually get them
to finance the film is them to finance
the film and actually we show the whole
process of how does it work the goal of
this whole film is transparency you're
gonna see the whole thing take place in
this movie so that's the the whole
concept the whole film start to finish
and I would love for scene journey to
help make it happen yeah you know it's
funny because when I first hear it it is
the ultimate respect for an audience
I don't know how receptive people are
going to be to it though
you have a perspective or do you I don't
want to use angle because that has sort
of has a negative connotation but do you
think that do you sort of know how this
is gonna play out no idea how much money
did it take to do this
1.5 million they're good I think that
you're gonna have a hard time meeting
with them but I think it's you know
certainly worth pursuing a couple really
big obvious brands who knows maybe by
the time your film comes out we look
like a bunch of blundering idiots what
do you think the response is gonna be I
the responses mostly will be no but as
the toughest cell because the felmers
tough sell because of me
both that meaning I'm not so optimistic
so can you help me I need help I can
help okay good good awesome yeah we got
a fight figure out which brands yeah
that's that's the challenge when you and
you look at like the people you deal
with we've got some places we can go
okay I'll turn the camera
I thought turn the camera off meant
let's have an off-the-record
conversation turns out it really means
we want nothing to do with your movie
and just like that one by one all of
these companies suddenly disappeared
none of them wanted anything to do with
this movie I mean I was amazed they
wanted absolutely nothing to do with
this project and I mean I was blown away
because I thought the whole concept the
idea of advertising was to get your
product out in front of as many people
as possible to get them as many people
to see it as possible especially in
today's world this this intersection of
new media and old median the fractured
media landscape isn't the idea to get
that new buzz worthy delivery vehicle
that's going to get that message to the
masses now that's what I thought but the
problem was you see my idea had one
fatal flaw and that flaw was this
actually no that was not the flaw
whatsoever that would've been a problem
at all see this would have been fine but
what this image represents was the
problem see when you do a google image
search for transparency this is
this is one of the first images that
comes up so I like the way you roll
sergey brin no this this was the problem
transparency free from pretense or
deceit easily detected or seen through
readily understood characterized by
visibility or accessibility of
information especially concerning
business practices that last line being
probably the biggest problem you see we
hear a lot about transparency these days
you know our politicians say it our
president says it even our CEOs say it
but suddenly when it comes down to it
becoming a reality something suddenly
changes but why
well transparency is scary like that odd
still screaming bear it's unpredictable
[Music]
like this odd country road and it's also
very risky what else is what else is
risky eating an entire bowl of Cool Whip
that's very risky no when I started
talking to companies you know and
telling them you we wanted to tell this
story and they said no we want you to
tell a story we want you to tell a story
the way we just want to tell our story
see when I was a kid and my father would
catch me in some sort of lie Mary is
giving me the look he often gave me he
would say son there's three sides to
every story there's your story there's
my story and there's the real story now
you see with this film we wanted to tell
the real story but with only one company
one agency willing to help me and that's
only because I knew John Bonham Richard
Kirshenbaum for years I realized that I
would have to go on my own I'd have to
cut out the middleman and go to the
companies myself you know myself with
all of my team so well you suddenly
started realize or what I started
realized that we started having
conversation with these companies the
idea of understanding your brand is a
universal problem I have friends who
make great big giant Hollywood films and
I have friends who make little
independent films like I make and the
friends might make big giant Hollywood
movies say that the reason their films
are so successful is because of the
brand partners that they have and then
my friends who make small independent
films say well how are we supposed to
compete with these big giant Hollywood
movies and the movie is called the
greatest movie ever sold and so now how
specifically what we see banned in the
film it's any time I'm getting ready to
go any time I open up my medicine
cabinet you will see ban deodorant well
any time
do an interview with someone I could say
are you are you fresh enough for this
interview are you are you ready look a
little nervous
I want to help you calm down so maybe
you should maybe you should put some on
for the interview this little offer you
know one of this fabulous says whether
it's a floral fusion or paradise wins
you know they'll have their chance you
know what we will have have them geared
for both male or female you know solid
roll-on or stick whatever maybe that's
the that's the two cent tour so now I
can answer your questions and give you
the five-cent tour we are a smaller
brain much like you talked about being a
smaller you know movie are very much a
challenge of brands so we don't have the
budgets that other brands have so doing
things like this you know remind people
about ban is kind of why we're
interested in it what are the words that
you would use to describe ban ban is
blank
technology's not the way you want to
describe something somebody's put in
their armpit you're talking about bold
oh yeah fresh guyhnic fresh is a great
word that really spins this category
into the positive versus a fights odor
and when this right it's keeps you fresh
fresh either we keep you fresher longer
better freshness more freshness three
times fresher things like that that are
you know more of that positive benefit
and that's a multi-million dollar
corporation what about me what about a
regular guy I need to go talk to the man
on the street the people who are like me
the regular Joe's they need to tell me
about my brand how would you guys
describe your brand
my brain
I don't know like
all right really nice clothes eighties
revival meets skater Punk
unless it's laundry day right what is
brand Jerry unique unique I guess what
kind of genre style I am would be like
dark glamour I like a lot of black
colors a lot of Gray's and stuff like
that but usually some that have an
accessory like sunglasses or I like
crystal and things like that too
if Dan were a brand he might be a
classic convertible I'm insane
the brand that I am is I would call it
casual fly part hippy part yogi part
Brooklyn girl I don't know I'm the pet
guy
I sell pet toys all over the country all
over the world so I guess that's my
brand in my warped little industry
that's my brand my brand is FedEx
because I deliver the goods failed
writer alcoholic brand is that something
I'm a lawyer brand I'm Tom well we can't
all be brand Tom but I do often find
myself at the intersection of dark
glamour and casual fly what I realize I
needed an expert I need someone who
could get inside my head somebody who
could really help me understand what
they call your brand personality and so
I found a company called Olsen's Altman
in Pittsburgh who they've helped
companies like Nestle Febreze hallmark
discover that brand personality if they
could do it for them surely they could
do it for me
you brought your pictures right I did
the very first picture is a picture of
my family so tell me a little bit how it
relates to your thoughts and feelings
about anyway these are the people who
shaped the way I look at the world tell
me about this world I think it's the I
think your world is the world that you
live in like people that are around you
your friends your family the the way you
live your life a job you do like all
those things stemmed and started from
one place and for me there's them
installed with my family in West
Virginia what's the next one going to
talk about the next one this was the
best day ever
how does this relate to thoughts and
feelings about who you are there's like
who do I want to be I like things that
are different I like things that are
weird things
tell me about the Y phase what does that
do for us what does the Michelle people
state genuine now as important
what is the red represent
[Music]
thank you thank you yeah thanks for your
patient great job yeah yeah I don't know
what's gonna come of this there was a
whole lot of crazy going on in there the
first thing we saw was this idea that
you had two distinct but complementary
sides to your brand personality the
Morgan Spurlock brand is a mindful play
brand those are kind of juxtaposed very
nicely together and I think there's
almost a paradox with those and I think
some companies will just focus on one
one of their strengths or you know or
the other instead of focusing on both
most companies tend to it's human nature
to avoid things that they're not sure of
avoid fear those elements and you really
embrace those and you actually turn them
into positives for you it's a neat thing
to see what other brands are like that
the first one here is a classic Apple
and you can see here to target we mini
from Mini Coopers and JetBlue now
there's playful brands and mindful
brands those sort of things that have
come and gone but a playful mindful
brand is a pretty powerful thing
a playful mindful brand what is your
brand if somebody actually described
your brand identity your brand
personality what would you be are you an
up attribute are you something that gets
the blood flowing are you more of a Down
attribute are you something a little
more calm reserved conservative up
attributes are things like being playful
being fresh like The Fresh Prince
contemporary adventurous edge you're
daring like Errol Flynn nimble or agile
profane domineering magical or mystical
like Gandalf are you more of a Down
attribute are you mindful sophisticated
like double-oh-seven are you established
traditional nurturing protective
empathetic like the Oprah are you
reliable stable familiar safe secure
sacred contemplative or wise like the
Dalai Lama or Yoda over the course this
film we had 500 plus companies who were
up and down company say no they didn't
want any part of this project they
wanted nothing to do with this film
mainly because they had no control they
would have no control over the final
product but we did get 17 brand partners
who were willing to relinquish that
control who wanted to be in business
with someone as mindful and as playful
as myself
and who ultimately empowered us to tell
stories that normally we wouldn't be
able to tell stories that an advertiser
would normally never get behind they
enabled us to tell the story about neuro
marketing as we got into the telling the
story in this film about how now they're
using MRIs to target the desire centers
of your brain for both commercials as
well as movie marketing we went to San
Paolo where they abandoned or
advertising in the entire city for the
past five years there's no billboards
there's no posters there's no flyers
nothing and we went to school districts
where now companies are making their way
into cash-strapped schools all across
America what's incredible for me is the
the projects that I've gotten the most
feedback out of are I've had the most
success and are ones where I've
interacted with things directly and
that's what these brands did they cut
out the middleman they cut out their
agencies and said maybe these agencies
don't have my best interests in mind I'm
gonna deal directly with the artist I'm
gonna work with him to create something
different something that's going to get
people thinking that's gonna challenge
the way we look at the world and how is
that been for them has it been
successful
well since the film premiered at the
Sundance Film Festival let's just take a
look according to Burrell's the movie
premiered in January and since then and
this is heating the whole thing we've
had more than 900 million media
impressions for this film
that's literally covering just like a
two and a half week period that's only
online no print no TV the film hasn't
even been distributed yet it's not even
online it's not even streaming it's not
even been out into other foreign
countries yet so ultimately this film
has already started to gain a lot of
momentum and not bad for a project that
almost every ad agency we talked to
advise their clients not to take part
what I always believe is that if you
take chances if you take risks that in
those risks will come opportunity I
believe that when you push people away
from that you're pushing them more
towards failure I believe that when you
train your employees to be risk-averse
then you're preparing your whole company
to be reward challenged I feel like that
what has to happen moving forward is we
need to encourage people to take risks
we need to encourage people to not be
afraid of opportunities that may scare
them ultimately moving forward I think
we have to embrace fear we've got to put
that bear in a cage
embrace fear embrace risk one big
spoonful at a time we have to embrace
risky and ultimately we have to embrace
transparency today more than ever a
little honesty is going to go a long way
and that being said through honesty and
transparency my entire talk embrace
transparency has been brought to you by
my good friends at EMC who for $7,100
bought the naming rights on eBay
[Music]
ENC turning big data into big
opportunity for organizations all over
the world
EMC presents embrace transparency thank
you very much guys
[Music]
morgen
in the name of transparency what exactly
happened to that $7,100 that is a
fantastic question I have in my pocket
a check made out to the parent
organization of the Ted foundation the
sapling foundation they check for $7,100
to be applied towards my attendance for
next year's tag
[Applause]